hey what's up my beautiful webs diavolo
here and today we're going to go over
megami fishigiro and his abilities so
far in the juju sukaisen universe
usually i'd like to talk about his
history as well so far in this series
but with him being a supportive main
character he has got a ton to go over
so instead i've decided to split it into
two different parts if you're strictly
anime only
look out for spoilers as we'll be going
over some of the feats that megami has
done recently in the manga i'll do my
best though to save them for the end of
the video so just look out for the
spoiler warning when it does pop
up anyways enough of the explanation
let's get into the abilities
of miguemi fushigiro megami entered the
jujutsu technical school as a grade two
sorcerer he is considered to have a high
potential by naratoshi kamo
maya zenin satoru and even sukuna
megami's willingness to use hand-to-hand
combat makes him different from other
shikigami users according to gojo megami
has even more potential and skill than
yuji he is able to use physical attacks
in combination with his shikigami to
entrap his opponent
while not as strong as yuji megami has
been shown to possess
a high level of physical proficiency
kinda like yuji is with his speed and
strength just to a lesser degree
but still compared to a normal child
their age it is just mental like for
example
look at when he was in junior high and
easily beat up half the punks in his
area
although megami's technique makes it
difficult for him to wield weapons at
the same time as his shikigami need both
hands to be summoned he has started to
train with pole arms under maki zenon
he also once used the tonthe in his fire
with naratoshi kmo during the kyoto
goodwill event arc
megami has showcased a high level of
tactical thinking he is very capable of
quickly spotting weaknesses opponents
may have
being the person to recognize hanami's
branches as his weak spot
inheritor techniques are techniques
passed down through specific families in
the jujutsu kaizen universe
some of the inherited techniques in this
series are cursed speech and blood
manipulation
megami's inherited technique is that of
the xenon families and is the ten
shadows technique
when someone inherits the ten shadows
technique they receive two divine dogs
other shikogami can be summoned with an
exorcism ritual where the user must
defeat the shukyami in order to make
them submit once dominated the shukugami
are under full control of their master
and can be summoned using hand signs
that create a shadow puppet of their
respective familiar
the shadows act as the intermediary for
the shikigami conjuration reflecting the
shape of the user's hand-weaved shadow
puppet and manifesting the shigegami
from tangible liquid shadows using
cursed energy
after gaining more familiars the user
can repeat the ritual process to
exercise and amass up to 10 different
shikigami
the summoning ritual for the shikagami
can be performed around multiple
people however exercising the shigegami
with help
nullifies the technique once the
exorcism is completed
the ten shadows technique can be
activated and deactivated at any time
to manifest and dispel shikigami as long
as the user
has enough cursed energy as with any
shikigami the more powerful it is the
more cursed energy it requires to summon
shikigami of the ten shadows cannot be
summoned when completely destroyed
however the power left behind by the
shikigami is inherited by the others
in the case of the divine dog shikagami
if one dies the other will inherit its
power
and can be summoned in a far more
ferocious form the exception to this
rule are any shigegami that are summoned
by combining two different shadows such
as the wells unknown abyss
mekomi can also use the ten shadows
technique to access a storage area that
contains various different graded
weapons that he can pull out at any
moment during a fight
the current chikigami that we have seen
megami create and the anime are divine
dogs
divine dog totality nue great serpent
orochi the toad the whale's unknown
abyss
and max elephant divine dogs
fishy guru summons two black and white
shikagami dogs that chase and devour
curses
megami uses divine dogs to defeat weaker
curses with their offensive abilities
they are also useful for tracking scents
and able to ward megami of incoming
curses or lead him to specific targets
laser after the white divine dog was
destroyed by the finger bearer its
abilities and cursed energy were
inherited by the black divine dog
creating
divine dog totality divine dog totality
is an improved version
of the black divine dog shikagami which
inherited the powers of the fallen white
divine dog
using totality the black divine dog
transforms into a larger bipedal
werewolf like
being with large claws it can be
summoned by megami fushiguro's ten
shadows technique and is powerful enough
to contend with special grade cursed
spirits
nue an owl like shikayami that can fly
strong enough to carry a human its
offensive abilities are mostly dive
attacks from the sky
but it does seem to also possess some
electrical type ability
as we see in episode 18 during the final
moments of the battle between naratoshi
and megami before enumaki shows up with
a special grade curse close on his tail
interrupting the fight it's also useful
for defense in a pinch
nue's speed and dense wings allow for a
powerful defense against physical
attacks noe showed this ability by
defending megami from a direct hit from
sukuna
however nue was unable to continue
fighting afterwards and was called back
by megumi
the great serpent orochi a giant snake
shikagami which can be used as a
surprise attack coming out of the ground
and binding the opponent
in the fight with sukuna megami used
great serpent's quick summon to his
advantage
it served as an effective surprise
attack that caught sacuna in the snake's
mouth and held him immobile high in the
air
this allowed norway to repeatedly strike
sukuna while he was bonded
however sukuni escaped moments later
ripping the great serpent apart and
completely destroying the shikigami
toad is multiple large toads that use
their tongue to pin opponents and hold
them down
toad is mainly a support type that
megami refused to as quite weak
megami used toad's tongue to quickly
snatch nabarro's body out of harm's way
it also carried nabarro to safety in his
mouth
showcasing that along with a divine dog
it can be a useful search and rescue
tool
the wells unknown abyss using a
combination of two shikigami
toad and noe these toads can fly with
increased mobility as well as use their
tongues to restrain opponents
unlike its parent shikigami these toads
are relatively weaker but can be
destroyed without consequence and can be
summoned as long as noe and toad are
alive mekomi first used this technique
to fight against todo in episode 8.
max elephant is a large elephant with
black markings on its forehead the top
of its head
its back and its knees using the ten
shadows technique the user lays one hand
on top of the other and adjusts their
fingers to create a shadow paper of an
elephant head the elephant is summoned
from the user's
shadow but this requires some time as
well as a large amount of cursed energy
max elephant is capable of unleashing a
massive torrent of water from its trunk
the water is blasted with enough
volume and pressure to flood an entire
corridor and force naratoshi through a
solid wall to the outside of the
building this allowed megami to set up a
follow attack using norway since
naratoshi was virtually defenseless in
mid-air
okay guys so at this moment as episode
23 has been the latest episode to air
i've decided that from this point
onwards everything is considered a
spoiler for anyone who hasn't read up to
the end of the shibuya incident arc and
the manga
well that's your warning now let's
continue with megami and his abilities
the rest of his abilities that we have
seen so far in the manga
are rabbit escape eight handled sword
divergent silla divine general maharaga
and his barrier technique chimera snow
garden which you will see hopefully in
either episode 24 or 25 of the anime
rabbit escape by forming a shadow puppet
of a rabbit's head with their hand
the user's shadow summons a swarm of
dozens of rabbits
they are weaker and harmless shikagami
that serves as a distraction in a battle
that uses their numbers to cut off the
target's field of view
mikami fushiguru first used rabbit
escape to retreat with yuji in the
middle of their fight with jiro awasaka
eight handled sword divergent sailor
divine general maharaga
is the most powerful shikagami that may
be summoned via ten shadows technique
so far not a single user of the
technique
has been able to exercise maharaga
divine general maharaga
is a towering humanoid figure with
blades extending from its forearms
and four wings coming from its eye
sockets hovering just above the neck is
a large wheel
with eight handles that continually
rotates in response to new stimuli
because it has never been exercised and
tamed by a sorcerer maharaga
cannot be used or commanded like other
shikigami
however users of the ten shadows
technique are able to summon it as many
times as they want to attempt an
exorcism
this means they are able to summon it as
an absolute last resort against an enemy
forcing their opponent to take part in
the ritual
and to fight the general with him the
intention of the summoning is for
maharaga to kill everyone in the ritual
divine general maharaga has the strength
to shatter concrete with a single blow
and throw someone through multiple
buildings with ease
it can also wield sword of extermination
which envelops its
blades with positive energy making it a
specialist weapon against curses
who are born of negative energy
maharaga's true talent lies in the
ability to defensively adapt to any
and all phenomena as the 8-handle wheel
above its back turns this means that
maharaga
rapidly heals and can develop effective
countermeasures to all enemies and curse
techniques and may come into contact
with as the wheel turns
it is speculated that it does not just
adapt to specific techniques
rather it seems to adapt to a specific
attack
such as adjusting to all slashing
attacks instead of just sakuna's
dismantle technique alone during their
fight this rapid regeneration and
physical adaption means that maharaga
can only be defeated by bombard
it with new attacks so heavily and so
quickly that its entire body is
completely destroyed before the wheel
can start turning
and finally chimera shadow garden is the
main expansion
of the ten shadows technique used by
megami for shiguro while still
incomplete
chimera shadow garden floods the area
with thick fluid shadows this grants the
user the ability to manifest multiple
shikigami
as well as advance the manipulation of
all available shadows
megami first manifested chimera shadow
garden by freely imagining himself
going beyond his limits the activation
of this technique used all of megami's
cursed energy
resulting in physical backlash this also
resulted in an incomplete domain
expansion but was still effective enough
to enhance megami's ten shadow technique
the floor of the floated shadows can
quickly reshape itself into black toads
that can grab onto megami's target he
can also surf these frogs to move
quickly across the waves of shadows at
high speeds multiple versions of noise
can be created as well capable of flying
around
and attacking the opponent rapidly aside
from creating more shigegami
megami's manipulation of the shadows
improved greatly as well after suffering
what appeared to be a fatal blow nigami
was able to fake out his opponent with a
shadow double in order to finish the
fight against the finger bearer megami
used his amplified 10 shadows technique
to hide in the curse's shadow with
divine dog totality and doubt the
killing blow from behind
during the shibuya incident arc megami
used chimera shadow garden to enter
dagon's domain
he entered through a large explosive
geyser of shadows that could expand to
his allies this allowed maki to access
the weapon cache within mega me shadows
or more specifically
playful cloud so anyway for now this is
all i can find about megami for shiguro
and his abilities in jiu jitsu kaizen
if you'd like to know more about him and
his history and the jujutsu kaizen
universe feel free to let me know down
below
i can't wait to see these next few
episodes coming up in the anime as we'll
get to see the camera shadow garden
along with megami body a special grey
cursed spirit if you have enjoyed the
video be sure to headbutt the out
of that like button and leave a comment
down below with whose abilities and
history you'd like to know more about
from the jujutsu kaizen universe if
you're new around here
feel free to subscribe for more similar
content to do with anime and gaming
but for now it's been your professional
degenerate diavolo and i'll see you guys
in the next video
bye
[Music]
you